le fondateur de Hopper cette application
mobile qui vous permet de dénicher des
billets d'avion au plus bas prix veut
maintenant s'attaquer à un enjeu de
taille la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique grâce au captage du carbone
dans l'air avec nous ce soir Frédéric
Lalande co-fondateur président chef de
la direction de Hopper qu'on retrouve à
Paris ce soir bonsoir et je dirais même
bonne nuit monsieur Lalonde
bonsoir vous créez des skys c'est le nom
de l'entreprise et vous dites que vous
voulez faire de cela
de faire du Canada en quelque sorte la
capitale du capital du carbone
expliquez-nous ça
une compagnie qui est fondée pour
retirer le CO2 historique c'est à dire
tout ce qu'on a émis dans l'atmosphère
le capturer et le remettre sous terre
pour qu'il puisse se minéraliser ça
devenir de la roche on pourrait se poser
la question pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
besoin de faire ça c'est clair qu'on a
besoin de faire la transition
énergétique on devrait déjà aujourd'hui
être en train de capter le CO2 qui était
mis de nos usines mais il va falloir
retirer tout ce qui a été mis dans
l'atmosphère à l'intérieur des quelques
prochaines années quelques décennies la
raison c'est que en ce moment dans
l'atmosphère il y a 421 parties de CO2
par million et la dernière fois où c'est
arrivé la température terrestre était
plus chaude d'au moins 5 degrés et avec
60 mètres d'eau au dessus de la Floride
de New York et l'île de Montréal pour
arriver à restabiliser la terre peu
importe ce qu'on fait avec nos émissions
on va devoir arriver une stratégie de
retrait et la bonne nouvelle c'est que
au Canada et au Québec en particulier on
a une une panoplie de ressources
naturelles qui nous permettent de
démarrer cette industrie là donc est-ce
que pour vous c'est il y en a beaucoup
qui vont dire si on se met à capter du
carbone on repousse dans le fond les
gestes qui sont apposés pour réduire les
changements climatiques pour vous est-ce
que c'est la solution au réchauffement
climatique
c'est certain que si on capte le CO2
dans l'atmosphère pour se permettre de
continuer à brûler tous les énergies
fossiles ça fait aucun sens mais aucun
sens la première chose qu'on doit faire
c'est capter au niveau de nos cheminées
parce que de manière réaliste on pourra
pas faire la transition énergétique du
jour au lendemain on va continuer à
utiliser du pétrole du gaz naturel
d'ailleurs à l'échelle planétaire on
augmente encore même l'utilisation du
charbon il va falloir être réaliste
capter tout ça mais même si aujourd'hui
on fermait l'économie ici on ne commence
pas à faire le retrait du CO2 dès
maintenant on s'avance vers une
catastrophe à court terme en fait la
chose qui est la moins bien compris
c'est qu'il y a un délai entre
l'émission du CO2 et le réchauffement il
y a quelque part en 30 et 50 ans avant
qu'on ressente les effets ce qui veut
dire que ce qu'on a vu dans les
dernières années les rivières restaient
qu'en Europe les feux en Alberta les
tempêtes c'est même pas pour les
concentrations actuelles c'est pour les
concentrations à peu près à l'époque où
moi je suis né au début des années 70 à
long terme même le GIEC le dit ça va
nous prendre une stratégie de retrait et
c'est complémentaire qu'on le veuille ou
non il va falloir faire les deux pas
peur est une application une entreprise
qui nous encourage bien sûr à voyager à
meilleur prix certes mais ça reste ça
reste un voyage en avion là dans bien
des cas peu importe ce qu'on débourse ça
laisse une empreinte carbone que de
prendre l'avion avec ce que vous
confondez aujourd'hui débit Sky est-ce
que c'est une façon de faire contre
poisson
depuis 2019 on peut à l'aide de ce qu'on
appelle des crédits naturels on annule
les émissions de tout ce que nous
clients émettent en voyageant donc à
même les profits de l'entreprise on a
des projets de reforestation dans les
pays africains qui sont en place depuis
bientôt 4 ans on a 25 millions d'armes
qui ont été plantés et ce qu'on s'est
rendu compte c'est que c'était tout
simplement pas assez simplement parce
qu'un arbre prend 30 à 40 ans avant de
devenir productif et c'est face à
l'ampleur de l'accélération des impacts
qu'on s'est dit qu'il fallait faire plus
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
on a fondé des psychelles c'est pour
trouver une façon d'arriver réellement à
faire un impact à l'intérieur des
prochaines Décines et vous voulez même
lancer un premier projet pilote dès l'an
prochain mais pour ça ça prend de
l'argent si je me trompe pas ça vous
prend 50 millions de dollars comment
vous allez trouver ça
d'abord la compagnie a déjà élevée 10
millions de dollars au mois de novembre
l'an dernier Investissement Québec qui
est le bras de capital de risque du
gouvernement du Québec a fait le premier
financement ce qui nous a permis de
faire le tour de la planète de visiter
des garages de visiter un bon sous
Londres tous les espèces de projets en
développement et on s'est rendu compte
que la technologie elle existe elle
n'est pas vraiment au Québec surtout en
Californie un peu en Europe et que ce
qui nous manque vraiment c'est une
fédération de ces diverses
technologies-là pour arriver à ce qu'on
voit à l'écran en ce moment c'est à dire
une infrastructure qui est capable de
retirer des millions de tonnes par année
donc la première chose qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a levé du capital
gouvernemental et privé et là on est en
train de terminer le financement de 50
millions pour faire la première étape
l'offre de Hopper évolue pour celles et
ceux qui connaissent un peu votre
application vous faites à faire avec des
fournisseurs pour bonifier toute
l'expérience voyage je vous proposer des
nouvelles fonctionnalités le gel de prix
sur la location de voiture par exemple
est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de changer
l'image de Harper tel qu'on la connaît
d'attirer une nouvelle clientèle
il y a aucun lien direct entre les deux
c'est à dire que un client d'Apple a
aucune façon de savoir que je suis le
fondateur de cette compagne là la raison
pour laquelle on le fait c'est
réellement pour l'Impact là je suis
encore le président fondateur de Apple
c'est ce que je fais le jour c'est mon
premier travail mais quand on a commencé
à voir les impacts de la le
réchauffement global principalement
l'été dernier si vous êtes allé en
Europe vous avez vu les sécheresses on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
urgence complète et qu'on devait
commencer à lancer cette technologie là
et comme je l'ai dit plutôt le Québec
entre autres à cause de ces réserves
d'hydroélectricité entre autres à cause
de sa géologie pour stocker le CO2 sous
terre et l'endroit de rêve pour faire
démarrer cette industrie là et on a
l'impression aussi qu'on va pouvoir
commencer à créer une richesse au niveau
de l'exportation des crédits qui est le
principal produit c'est-à-dire la tonne
négative de CO2 est un produit qui va se
vendre sur les marchés internationaux
mais c'est très intéressant en tout cas
on va suivre de près l'évolution de
votre projet Frédéric Lalonde merci de
nous en avoir parlé ce soir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]